je m'appelle Marie-Hélène Cardet j'ai 17
ans je suis fermière normande
j'ai 12 vaches qui sont normandes j'ai
deux frères et une sœur qui sont normaux
et puis qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
maintenant que vous êtes la meilleure
ménager rurale c'est difficile de
devenir ménagé c'est très difficile
qu'est-ce qu'il faut savoir faire
si par exemple
tout l'agricole
traire une vache
faire le beurre
la bonne petite ménagère que voilà mais
dites donc vous êtes prêtes à voir un
mari influencé maintenant
c'est vrai vrai pas encore mais il va
venir vite voyez on sonne déjà c'est le
téléphone c'est un fiancé qui vous
demande ah merci Marielle